I sunny 16 no we call that the wedge
you know what is this game baseball this
guy was made yourself signed to the eggs
you were Yankee almost I made the
biggest mistake of my life that night so
do you have a plan
maybe something in management really you
barely have a high school diploma okay
still culture you add this stuff to be
one of the great yeah but I'm not says
you've been back home it's a couple
weeks you know I'm sorry
yeah yeah wasn't they're not gonna want
to see you anymore this morning's you
move on it's gonna take a lot people get
used to you back I want you to meet that
kid certainly doesn't lack confidence
you can learn a lot from Sammy I want
you two to get to know each other okay
but I'm not gonna teach me so step off
your next superstar let's see what you
got hotshot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what would you say if I got you a spot
on the team and say you were crazy I
think you still got the goods I think
it's great baseball is who you are so
you always wear this and then Scouts to
see how many people don't want to see me
in a Yankee nice how things will falling
back into place for you but I just don't
trust myself do you trust your instinct
believe in yourself it's like a
one-of-a-kind story like baseball
history second chances are hard to come
by
be grateful you get me
it's throw a no-hitter against this this
might be I'll let it end this way then
I'll grab a back
[Music]
even like baseball no I like soccer you
know that
[Music]
you